que ressort-il de ces trois auditions de
ce matin notamment celle du chef de
cabinet françois xavier loches de
grandes zones d'ombré demeurent encore
sur la fonction d'alexandre benalla on
progresse pas à pas le chef de cabinet
du président de la république nous a
précisé que monsieur benalla avec une
fonction de coordination des services de
sécurité on s'approche de la
reconnaissance qu'ils jouaient bien un
rôle en matière de sécurité
nous voulons maintenant approfondir
cette question il ya d'un côté un permis
de port d'armes réclamé par l'elysée et
qui invoque la fonction police qu'il
exerçait il ya d'un autre côté une
définition de fonction qui jusqu'à
aujourd'hui reposait essentiellement sur
l'organisation de déplacements publics
et privés sous l'organisation des
invitations très nombreuses de
concitoyens pour le 14 juillet là on
voit que il ya une meilleure explication
sur le fait qu' il avait un rôle en
matière de sécurité et les images que
l'on voit les vidéos les photos
attestent quand même que du moins
peut-on dépenser ils avaient une
fonction de protection rapprochée ce qui
amène de notre part le chef de cabinet
continue à le nier mais oui c'est pour
ça alors il y à un pas dans la direction
d'une reconnaissance d'un rôle en
matière de sécurité
c'est vrai mais il ya toujours une
un refus d'admettre qu'il pouvait avoir
une fonction de protection rapprochée
malgré le permis de port d'armes
et ça c'est compliqué à comprendre et
nous allons donc continuer notre notre
travail d'investigation et puis vraiment
notre âme et conscience nous diront les
conclusions que nous en tirerons et puis
nous ferons des propositions pour
améliorer le bon fonctionnement de
l'état et notamment sur ces questions de
sécurité on a entendu le général
bio-farina tout de même qui a parlé d'un
rôle d'interface entre le gspr et le
commandement militaire alors
l'organisation va quand même jusqu'au
forces de sécurité
c'est cohérent avec ce qu'a dit le chef
de cabinet quand il a parlé de
coordination
donc je crois que nous nous approchons
du coeur du sujet qui est au fond la
protection du chef de l'état ça n'est
pas une affaire secondaire c'est une
affaire qui concerne tous les français
pour que nous puissions continuer à
avoir une protection du chef de l'état
qui correspondent aux standards
internationaux
les meilleurs et ça suppose pas
d'interférence d'agents qui ne sont pas
ni des gendarmes ni des policiers qui
sont pas formés au même degré de
performance sans doute que les
professionnels juste une toute dernière
question sur une réponse à alexandre
benalla ce qu'il a dit ce matin en
disant que les parlementaires étaient de
petite personne en disant que la
commission d'enquêté allait à l'encontre
de la démocratie
est ce que vous confirmez la date c'est
à dire que la semaine prochaine il sera
auditionné le 19 ans avait deux
questions sur la première écoute et ça
ne mérite pas de commentaire il faut que
monsieur benalla prennent conscience de
l'importance de la représentation
nationale dans notre pays
et puis à cordes à celle ci fut le
respect minimal qu'on est en droit
d'attendre de tous nos concitoyens dans
l'exercice de notre mission qui consiste
à faire en sorte que l'état fonctionne
bien et améliorer le fonctionnement
quand il ya des dysfonctionnements
quant à l'audition de
monsieur benalla comme ça a été dit et
redit
elle devrait normalement avoir lieu le
19 septembre au matin